>From the high level description of what happens on page faults and how it is
handled, you can see that the behavior of
this GMS global memory management, is as follows.
So overtime, you can see that if there is an idle node in the land, then
that idle node, its working set is continuously
going to decrease as it accommodates more and
more of its peers pages that are swapped out to fit in its global cache. And
eventually a completely idle node, becomes a memory
server, for peers on the network. So that's the
expected behavior of this logarithm. And the key
attribute of the logarithm is the fact, that
the split between Local and Global is not
static, but is dynamic, depending on what is happening
at a particular node. For instance, even the
same node, if it was serving as a memory
server for my peers, because I had gone
out to lunch, I come back, and start actively
using my workstation. In that case, I'm going to
go back, and the community service part of my
machine is going to start decreasing. So the Local
Global split is not static, but it shifts depending
on what local memory pressure exist at that node.